In this lesson, we're going to take a look at screen space global illumination and how
that works.
So let's get started.
So using screen space global illumination, keep in mind that it is beta.
It's been there for a bit.
It allows us to have a really quick on screen global illumination solution.
Now if you are using it with baked lighting, because you can use it outside of baked lighting,
and we go into that in other classes, but in this particular case, we'll talk a little
bit more focused on the baked lighting side.
You want to make sure when you are using it with baked lighting that you have your baked
lighting already set in because it is complementary.
It doesn't replace it, but it is complementary in that particular scenario.
It can also be turned on in your post process volume, which I'll show you in just a second.
In your indirect lighting, strength can also be controlled too.
So let me show you what I mean.
So in Unreal, we already have things pre-baked out here, and we're using screen space global
illumination.
And again, what I mean by you being able to turn this on in two different places, if we
go to our edit project settings and we go back under rendering, when I showed you previously
to edit things for baking or for lumen.
Let's go there.
We went too far.
Let's go back up.
So we go down here.
You can see we're in screen space global illumination under dynamic global illumination method.
And we're using shadow maps because this is more of the baked scenario.
And again, this is the old school way to do things with Unreal.
And you can use screen space global illumination when it comes to lumen.
You can mix things up.
Let's actually talk about that post process ability to mix things up here.
So I'm going to go and type in post process volume.
Let's go and call that up.
And we can scroll down and see what our global illumination method is.
Now in our project settings, we know they're already set, but we can override things here.
So I can set this to screen space global illumination.
You saw a momentary error there because Unreal's all, there's no way you can do this for you
because we don't have the settings for lumen.
But now we're in screen space here.
In screen space, we can actually control how things or the strength of things are when
it comes to global illumination.
And what I mean by that is we can actually adjust that indirect lighting.
Let me show you how that works.
You'll see under advanced, we can click on this and we can control indirect lighting
intensity.
See that?
So we're actually controlling how that light is being bounced around and the strength
of it in our environment.
We can also adjust a color if we need a particular color.
This is really great to be able to have this option in here.
Now this is in a baked scenario.
You can also use this in lumen as well as with ray tracing.
But when you do that, you have to make sure you know exactly where your settings are at.
So case in point, if I'm using screen space global illumination in my GI, am I using it
in my reflections?
Well, if we had it to ray trace, we could use ray trace reflections and still use screen
space global illumination.
We could use lumen global illumination, and I'm not sure why you would, but you could
use screen space reflections.
All these things are adaptable, but you have to remember where things are at.
So I like to keep things either lumen or not lumen.
But if I'm in ray tracing, maybe something might be expensive, I can easily switch my
global illumination instead of ray tracing GI, go to screen space.
You can see ray tracing GI down below.
And it does say deprecated, but don't let that fool you.
In our next class, we talk about ray tracing.
In our next advanced classes, I should say, we talk about it.
We talk about the ins and outs of this.
Now this is going to be around for a bit, but some of these things are actually already
incorporated with lumen, hence the name deprecated.
So it's still going to be around, so don't think that it's going to disappear just yet.
So the nice thing about using this is you can actually see these items glowing on screen.
Now the disadvantage you run into is when using screen space, as you turn your camera,
you can lose some of the stuff that it may be affected.
Now I'm fooling the eye here.
I'm actually using a rec light to make it look like there's a little bit more glowing
going on, but that anything like a glowing material, such as this little green area,
there can be some clipping occurring.
Today, Unreal's working like a champ and no clippings happening, but if I turned my camera
past a certain point, I would actually get some clipping and that would disappear.
So just be aware of that if you have glowing objects and you want them to, say, relate
to other objects, and we can cheat a little bit here.
And I'll get a simple piece of geometry in here.
Pull it up to that green area.
Maybe we can see that effect.
We'll get really close to see if that green light.
There may be too many lights in here for this to actually give off any reasonable reaction.
You would see things clipping go away as I turn my camera here.
You can see a little bit of that there.
See that geometry that has bounced light disappear here off the orb right around this part on
the very rim of the geometry.
You'll actually see that disappear.
And that's what I mean.
Some of those, as you turn your camera, will go away.
You would have to use over scan if you're using ICV effects.
If you were to use this effect, you would have to do it within your NDC properties,
your camera properties, to be able to compensate for that.
So just keep those things in mind.
Note, the effect can also be used for interiors and interiors and the objects can be animated,
but do be careful of how that clipping happens.
So just be aware of it.
It can be tricky.
You'll also see we have reflection capture resolution.
We also have reflection screen space.
You can actually use also screen space for your reflections, but it's not as accurate.
So you may want to mix and match if you can.
Just be aware of that.
There can be some banding going on, obscure type of looks and feels for things.
So again, limitations.
Screen space is based on your camera and 3D space, like we mentioned.
You'll notice clipping, which I demonstrated.
Also when you're using it, you need to have some sort of baked data in place if you're
using it with baked data.
It was created to complement baking in place and not replace it.
You can use it with ray tracing if you wish, and you can use it.
And again, I wouldn't really recommend it, but you could if you wanted to, saying Lumen
is giving you too much noise.
You can turn off Lumen GI and switch the screen space with some Lumen reflectivity in some
areas.
You can do that.
Just be aware of how things are placed in the scene, because the more you stack things
up, the more you mix and match.
There could be other conditions and situations happening with your material, with your lighting,
with your reflectivity.
Just make sure you're managing how things go and understanding the limitations for all
of these.
That's about it with this course.
Here's a link to get you deeper into the subject and understand the material better.
In the next course, we're going to take a look at GPU lightmass and we'll do a quick
overview on how that works.
Thanks again.